from what I understand you and Jed were
dating for about four months if you had
known that him going on the Bachelorette
was a possibility and then you
ultimately knew that he was going to go
on the show and it seems the plan was
for you two to continue dating once he
got off the show because you're saying
he told you he only went on the show for
his career you know it all it started
you know just like any other couple and
probably three weeks into us dating he
came forward basically said you know
I've been talking about mom about this
and you know I just don't think there's
any way I can you know we can go forward
I kind of see where this is going and I
don't feel right not giving the chance
to walk away like you know I have to be
a friend about it so I'm like you know
okay
here's this person that I'm falling for
really quickly you know we obviously out
this straight connection and the grand
scheme of things we live in Nashville
where people are during reality shows
and the boys in American Idol and music
city and all these things that you sign
these contracts and it's all sort of
hypothetical until you know casting
casting and casting goes on the months
did you guys discussed hey I could
really fall for this person well I said
you could really fall for this person
and you know keep this is a person that
I'm very much in love with telling me I
love you I'm not gonna fall for her so
do I have concerns about being in love
with someone who you're saying was
willing to go on a show and lie to
another woman you know the thing is it's
just like this is a very strange
scenario and we're in a very interesting
you know the entertainment business is
not like you know I need to move to
Arkansas for my career moves you know
it's like okay this is a huge
opportunity and truly I mean look at
what a platform it is obviously I've
looked back on this and there are so
many like I read text messages that I
sent that online
this is embarrassing why did I like how
could I let myself be here like how can
I have let myself believe this you fell
in love with this person so clearly you
saw some good in him so I'm gonna ask
you do you think that if he has maybe
told Hannah about this we haven't seen
all the show maybe he told her about you
too and should she forgive him I hope
sir I don't think that he's a bad person
I don't know what happened there I don't
know if it's feelings just changed for
me I don't know if he only loves her I
don't know what this circumstances are
necessarily and I think he's a bad
person for any of it it solely this was
you know me coming forward I had people
reach I never plans to come forward I
didn't want to be involved I didn't want
anything through the show I have my own
things going on
but when I have people reaching out
saying my name it has been brought up to
them three times and they want the story
and they're gonna tell the story I'm
thinking okay well you're gonna tell the
story without me me coming forward with
the story or like my message with this
is my anyway negative toward anyone or
trying to be better for anyone so Lee
was keep it were saying but they're
gonna tell my story my story the real
girl my real wife and I was going to not
have any control of that just didn't
really seem fair that nobody's innocent
lynard so hearing the emotion in your
voice it sounds like I'm just putting
this out there you tell me if I'm
reading it wrong or right but it sounds
like what you're saying is that Jed hurt
your feelings by not explaining things
to you but that your feelings were real
that at the time his feelings for you
were real and that you don't necessarily
think he's a bad person but some
mistakes were made
Julie I mean I would not have fallen
head over heels for someone that's a bad
I mean it's beyond that she wouldn't
have if Hanna and Jed have ended up
together at the end of this how will you
feel guys this is the person that I love
that could just be engaged to someone
else so if they are that's right